[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the development of breath of the wild
lasted
around five years of which the first two
went pretty smoothly we went from a
completely pre-rendered teaser to the
first proper gameplay demonstration
in less than 6 months this gameplay
demonstration provided to us by series
former and current producer aj onuma and
suguru miyamoto at the game awards gave
us a taste of the sheer scope of the
game
and demonstrated some of the early
gameplay elements such as paragliding
and horse riding
they even gave us a sneak peek into the
full map of hyrule and as you can see
most of it had already been laid out we
do see some small differences
for instance even tide island has the
shape of a crescent moon something
that's no longer the case in the
finished project
additionally the lomme labyrinths are
missing death mountain didn't have a
central crater yet and the gerudo
highlands had some sort of a hole in the
west side of the mountain range
among other small changes but by far the
biggest difference compared to later
showings of the game is the absence of
the shika slate
despite this we do see anuma
demonstrating the pin feature
something that in the finished game is
done using the shika artifact
but in the demo it's simply done with a
very generic looking cursor
the now very recognizable sheika slade
ui is nowhere to be found
both while pinning as well as on the map
feature whether or not the team was
already working on the idea of the slade
at this point in time
is unknown what we do know is that its
inclusion as well as the physics that
came with it was the single
biggest culprit for the numerous delays
of the game in the years to come
in hindsight it's hard to imagine breath
of the wild without the chica slave
it was and still is one of the biggest
innovations for the series
and made breath of the wild the creative
playground it is today
okay that is just awesome although the
chica slate itself
may have been thought up later it's
clear that there's one aspect which
nintendo wanted to include from the very
get-go
technology zelda is and always has been
a series predominantly set in a medieval
time period with fantasy elements and
magic
but the use of high tech isn't
necessarily new to the franchise
we have seen hints of it in previous
titles like skyward sword
themes of ancient robots and factories
but never before did it play such a
central role to the point where most of
the narrative
is shaped by it the soon-to-release age
of calamity has shown to continue the
inclusion of said technology as both a
weapon
and as an enemy which makes sense seeing
how it predates the events of breath of
the wild by 100 years when the kingdom
was well on their way to unlocking the
ancient tech
until it was unexpectedly turned against
them
with the spotlights now on age of
calamity it's easy to forget that
oh yeah there's a sequel to breath the
wild still underway as well
and one might ask the important question
of will this general theme of technology
persist in that game and if you were to
ask me i would say
no and there are various reasons and
hints why i think this might be the case
both from a story or lore standpoint but
also from a gameplay perspective
so let's explore why the shika
technology might not make a return
in breath of the wild too
let's start off with the most obvious
and the one that's already been pointed
out by pretty much
everyone since the early days of
breathtak 2's reveal
the absence of shika technology in the
trailer the fact that we don't see any
of the towers or shrines during the
final shot where we see hyrule castle
rising
is a pretty significant detail now you
might say that well
this is just a trailer not an accurate
representation of the final game
and while i agree with that point of
view it's still again
a very specific detail this clearly
isn't something nintendo overlooked
in fact the opposite is more likely to
be true they would have had to actively
remove all the towers and shrines from
the map this also includes the five
pillars surrounding the castle
another thing that many have noticed is
that neither zelda nor
link is carrying the sheikah slate
during their venture into the dark caves
of hyrule's underground
something that's simply not logical from
a story perspective
the sheikah slate would be an essential
tool during an excavation like this
it could be used to map out the area
take photographs of important findings
not to mention a fearsome weapon in case
they run into any trouble
now of course it could be possible that
the slate is stuffed into one of the
numerous bags on the giant animal
but this too can be dismissed quite
easily as we know at some point in the
trailer the two leave the animal behind
at the bridge and some shots in the
trailer without a doubt take place
after this event and even then we never
see our heroes with the sheikah slate on
their person
the slate seems to be designed to be
carried on your hip or strapped to a
belt of some kind
and although zelda is wearing a cloak
which could conceal it we have plenty of
shots where we can clearly see her full
waist and still
no chica slay same goes for link again
it just wouldn't make sense not to carry
such an important piece of equipment in
a dangerous underground cave like this
especially considering that in the
memories from 100 years ago
zelda was pretty much inseparable from
the damn thing and was almost always
carrying it around
everywhere she went another hint as to
the possible absence of the sheik attack
is the true ending of breath of the wild
now we know that breath of the wild 2
was originally conceptualized as dlc
and what we got instead was a full-blown
sequel notice how the chosen lines for
zelda during the ending seems to be
very deliberate divine beast varuta
looks like it's stopped working
let's investigate the situation nintendo
was definitely setting something
up for a story event taking place after
calamity ganon's defeat as opposed to
the trial of the sword and the
champion's ballot which played out
before it
so with all that said the missing towers
pillars and shrines the lack of the
sheikah slate and varuta showing signs
of shutting down
how does this all tie together in order
to answer these questions we first need
to take a closer look at that which
powers the technological prowess
though it is clear that ancient energy
is a very potent and durable source of
power
it's also apparent that this resource is
definitely finite this is evident from
robbie and pera's tech labs which
require a constant supply of ancient
energy in order to remain operational
when the energy is no longer provided
the guidance stones which are crucial to
the research
shut down completely as far as we know
there are three
maybe four prominent locations around
hyrule where this energy can be
extracted from
somewhere in the depths of hyrule castle
on the outskirts of hattano village in
east necluda
and inside one of the hills in deepakala
additionally there may have actually
been an energy pocket close to the royal
ancient tech lab as well
as seen from all the blue flames burning
in one of the cutscenes in the demo of
age of calamity unless they somehow
managed to channel some of the energy
from the hyrule castle area which is
relatively close
but there is another location where
ancient energy has remained present
during the last 100 years
the great plateau first of all as we
know from the dlc
there's a huge trail located deep
beneath the plateau overseen by most
kosher but more importantly
despite all the towers and shrines
across hyrule being in a dormant state
the shrine of resurrection also remained
active all this time
which isn't surprising since it's a
medical facility after all
just like how in real life hospitals
have large backup generators which will
kick in in the case of a blackout
it makes sense that the shrine of
resurrection also has its own reserves
to keep it operational for as long as
possible
especially since the healing process
takes quite a while
it's likely that when the facility was
first discovered it had long since run
out of juice and needed to be
reactivated by pura and robbie which
brings us to the sheikah slate
it's never made clear where exactly the
slate was found but masterworks suggests
that
since the mechanism accepting the
sheikah slate in the shrine of
resurrection has only one pedestal that
presents a strong argument that it was
discovered here
we may never know for sure where the
relic was found since
even in age of calamity impa is already
in possession of it from the very
beginning
however it does hint at the fact that
even the sheikah slate can run out of
energy
before the tiny guardian activates it
it's clearly powered down
and judging from the reactions of impa
and zelda this is the first time they
see it operational
now obviously the sheikah slate's
battery beats the hell out of any
smartphone and can clearly last
months maybe even years without needing
a single charge but a hundred years
might be a bit of a stretch even for
this little powerhouse
which also totally explains why it was
placed inside the pedestal alongside
link in the shrine of resurrection the
slate was most likely tapping into the
energy reserves of the shrine so that by
the time link wakes up
it's fully charged and ready to go
unlike the shrine of resurrection which
runs independently the towers and other
shrines seem to operate as a network
a network which finds its origin at
hyrule castle
as masterworks illustrates in detail
quote it's possible that the great
plateau tower sent a signal to a central
control unit within hyrule castle which
in turn transmitted a signal to the
other towers and shrines throughout the
land
activating them all at once this
indicates that the towers and shrines
all draw
their energy from a central source that
being the energy pocket underneath the
castle
which this supposed central control unit
taps into
from what we can see from the game
itself is that the shrines and towers
have three different states
that being dormant with no light
emanating from it
standby mode indicated by an orange glow
and
active turning the light into a blue
color when it comes to the shrines
there's an obvious exception
since some shrines remain buried even
after the network has already been
activated
though the pedestals accompanying them
do glow an orange hue
indicating that even though the shrine
is buried it's still in a standby mode
and not dormant now it's obvious that
some kind of a mechanism is pushing the
shrines in the towers upwards whether
this
is because it's provided with ancient
energy from the central control unit or
because
some sort of a signal is sent to the
underground mechanism upon completing a
specific task
such as placing an orb inside a pedestal
or casting a shadow on it etc when it
comes to making the shrine
disappear however we know for a fact
that clearing it isn't the trigger to
make this happen
since even when link clears it and the
chica monk inside has departed the
shrine remains standing
but if a total loss of power were to
occur across hyrule it would
make sense that the shrines as well as
the towers retract back into the ground
since the mechanism holding it up is
also cut off or they might even be
programmed in a way that when its energy
level reaches a critical low point
the mechanism will automatically sink
the shrine or tower back into the depths
below
in turn if the central control unit
itself runs out
it slides out for all towers and shrines
since it's all connected to the same
network of ancient energy
this would explain why in the trailer
all the shika structures are
gone which begs the question what could
cause a total power outage to the point
where
everything including the divine beasts
and maybe even the sheikah slate shut
down completely
it has been speculated for a while now
that malus might actually be the source
of ancient energy
or at the very least that the energy is
an extension of it
in order to keep this video at a
reasonable run time i'll just let
nintendo black crisis explain the finer
details
since he already made an extensive video
about this subject which you can find
in the description the main gist of it
is that ancient energy
might be a purified form of malice the
reason for the existence of this theory
is that the green hand which is holding
ganondorf down
looks to be extracting malice upwards
through the hand and into the stone
formation seen on the ceiling
second is the fact that ancient machines
like guardians and divine beasts are
able to run on malice energy
something that shouldn't be possible if
the two were completely unrelated
that would be like trying to run a tesla
on gasoline except in the case of
ancient energy
ganondorf's essence has been removed
from the equation which
just makes so much sense the more i
think about it green energy
courage cancelling out red energy power
what are you left with
wisdom or blue energy another hint to
this being true lies in the similarities
between the shrine of resurrection
and the sanctum where calamity ganon
lays dormant throughout the events of
breath of the wild
the lead artist of the game makoto
euneso even makes a reference to this in
masterworks
by the way the shrine of resurrection
shares its layout with the throme room
in hyrule castle where ganon's cocoon is
and they were both designed around the
concept of revival
and indeed when we look at the two
structures they share
a lot of similarities in ganon's case we
can even see a substance being pumped
through these tubes leading into the
cocoon
we also see guardian husks entangled in
this web-like formation
it's no coincidence then that when ganon
emerges from his cocoon
his body has been fused with chica
technology as do his blights who not
only use shika technology like laser
cannons and guardian weapons but are
even able to power
and control the divine beasts it also
may present a case for why both
link and zelda didn't age in the last
100 years their bodies may have been
preserved by the same process
though in the case of zelda it could
also have something to do with the seals
he casted over herself and ganon but
hey i'm just keeping the options open
here and lastly
the game makes it clear that some if not
all sheik attack reacts to malice
for instance the five pillars buried
beneath hyrule castle who only started
rising up
on their own as soon as the demon king
made its big entree
as if reacting to his presence all this
hints towards a strong connection
between the malice and the technology
almost like a balance ancient energy
existing because of malice and in turn
used to remedy the very substance it
came from and because it takes so long
for ganondorf's malice to build up
the technology lies dormant most of the
time throughout history
but as the malice slowly builds up so
does the ancient energy
thus making the ancient text spring to
life as ganon's return draws near
now does this without a doubt prove the
relationship between the two substances
no but since ancient energy is a finite
resource which is continuously extracted
from the ground
and ganondorf happens to be on the
ground it is by far the most convincing
theory to go on
as of right now i mean the energy has to
come from somewhere right
[Music]
when link and zelda defeated calamity
ganon the malice which the demon king is
mostly made up of was sent to the void
gone his defeat could be the catalyst
leading into some of the tech starting
to shut down again
we've seen something similar happen
before to a smaller extent when ganon
was sealed inside the castle 100 years
ago
the guardians did remain operational
though no longer as coordinated as they
were before
and the divine beasts which no doubt
require a lot more energy
felt dormant and only started to move
again as the seal began to weaken
now of course this wouldn't be like a
regular blackout like we see with an
electrical grid
even after calamity ganon is gone
obviously some energy is still flowing
in various places like the shrine of
resurrection the sheikah slade and
whatever energy is still left in some of
the ancient cores or inside the ancient
furnaces
even the five pillars which have turned
back to their normal blue color
are still seen standing in the
background during the true ending
but sooner or later the central control
unit will run low and shut them down
and any other device dependent on
ancient energy will eventually suffer
the same fate
instead of an instant poof
it's more like a battery slowly running
low at some point
all technology will likely cease to
operate since its purpose is
tied to calamity ganon's presence as of
yet we don't exactly know how much time
has passed between breath the wild and
its sequel
it's not nearly long enough to the point
where link and zelda are showing clear
signs of aging
but from their appearance and especially
that of zelda it is hinted that at least
some considerable amount of time has
passed
could be months could even be a year or
two remember link and zelda are only 17
or 18
if you don't count the hundred years of
stasis they endured their appearance
isn't going to
radically change between 17 and 19.
either way
enough time could have passed to a point
where most if not all sheik attack has
run out of energy
including the sheikah slate who knows it
may even be the reason why they are set
on this journey underground
to investigate the origins of this
problem after all in the true ending
zelda does state
let's investigate the situation
even if everything i talked about
previously turns out to be wrong which
are of course still just theories not
facts there's also valid reasons for
abandoning the technology concept
in the sequel here in the real world
breath of the wild was heavily focused
on this technology concept
both in its gameplay and its story and
as mentioned before age of calamity is
following the same path as well since
it's basically an extension of
breathtak's narrative but a third game
with
again the same general focus might just
be too much of the same
for me personally that would definitely
be the case i'm really not convinced
that fighting guardians and conquering
divine beasts yet again
is going to be the right direction to
take the series in nintendo usually
doesn't repeat the exact same things
twice
then again nintendo also doesn't do
direct prequels with the same characters
made by a third party so
who knows anything at this point either
way nintendo
are innovators it's why each zelda game
looks and feels so radically different
and is always experimenting with new
gameplay elements while still retaining
the essence of a zelda game
sure the sheikah slate may be sorely
missed but there are plenty of other
ways to make the game play of breath the
wall 2
just as fun and experimental without
repeating the same thing
the whole concept of the shrines and the
divine beasts were already starting to
lose steam by the time the champion's
ballot came out
i'd rather see the sequel do something
completely different rather than feeling
like a glorified dlc
as much as i like the concept of the
guardians even from a story perspective
it wouldn't make a whole lot of sense if
they are still in the game i mean the
hylians would have to be pretty damn
stupid to keep these things around
oh sure let's keep the death machines
which are clearly very easily turned
against us and almost wiped out our
entire civilization operational
just in case if i were them i would make
sure that every single one of these
things
including the divine beasts are
dismantled and dumped out at sea
somewhere
and again purely from a gameplay
perspective it totally makes sense for
most chica-related tech to be gone
with the exception of maybe the towers
but the shrines would just be a waste of
space
since we already cleared them so what's
the point of keeping them around
another thing that comes to mind is that
zelda games usually see you starting
from the bottom again
now i don't know how they will pull this
off in terms of link's hearts and master
sword but i'm sure they'll find a clever
way around it but
what about the master cycle zero if we
keep that around we might as well just
throw the horses and stables out the
window
unless of course they suddenly start
dealing in motorcycles too
clearly nintendo could just take all
this stuff away without explanation but
weaving it into the story and giving a
proper reason as to why it's gone would
obviously be the better
choice especially since other story
elements like link already having the
master sword
do seem to carry over and that is all
for now
as always thank you for watching the
video views haven't exactly been the
best lately so
if you will spread the video around a
little bit and if you haven't subscribed
yet make sure to hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any future
uploads
i normally don't ask for these kinds of
things but yeah it's been kinda rough
lately
i also encourage you to share your
thoughts in the comments below do you
want to see the chica tech return in
breath to wall 2
or not or maybe only a select part of it
a special shout out goes to my amazing
patreons and my channel members who make
these videos possible
some of which have recently joined the
cause so say hello to
ast tattoo cat germ flash k
austin human center rhys richardson
adanor
merlin kuretz as well as a special
mention to nathaniel bogo and julian
clement for upgrading their pledge
you are all amazing and i cannot thank
you enough
i mean really i can't anyway i will see
you all in the next video this is dawn
signing off
and have a good one
[Music]